Traductor: María Inés Zazú
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Si no puedes imaginarte la vida
sin chocolate,
eres afortunado de haber nacido
después del siglo XVI.
Antes de ese momento, el chocolate
solo existía en Mesoamérica
con una forma bastante diferente
a la actual.
Hasta 1900 a.C.
el pueblo de esa región preparaba
los granos
del árbol de cacao autóctono.
Los registros antiguos informan
que los granos eran triturados
y mezclados con harina de maíz
y pimientos picantes
para crear una bebida,
no una relajante taza
de chocolate caliente,
sino una mezcla amarga,
vigorizante y espumosa.
Y si pensamos que hoy le damos
mucha importancia al chocolate,
los mesoamericanos nos ganaron.
Ellos creían que el cacao
era un alimento celestial
otorgado a los humanos
por el dios Serpiente Emplumada,
conocido por los mayas como Kukulkán
y por los aztecas como Quetzalcóatl.
Los aztecas usaban al cacao como moneda
y tomaban chocolate
en los banquetes reales,
se lo daban a soldados como recompensa
por el éxito en la batalla
y se usaba en rituales.
El primer encuentro transatlántico
con el chocolate ocurrió en 1519
cuando Hernán Cortés
visitó la corte de Moctezuma
en Tenochtitlán.
Como lo registró el teniente de Cortés,
el rey tenía 50 jarras de la bebida
que se ofrecía y vertía en copas de oro.
Cuando los colonizadores volvieron
cargando ese nuevo y extraño grano
las historias de los misioneros
sobre las costumbres nativas
le dieron al grano reputación
de ser afrodisíaco.
Al principio, se lo ofrecía
para dolencias por su gusto amargo,
como molestias estomacales,
pero al endulzarlo con miel,
azúcar o vainilla
se transformó en un popular
manjar en la corte española.
Pronto, un hogar aristocrático solo
era digno con vajilla para el chocolate.
La bebida de moda era difícil
y consumía mucho tiempo para producirse
en gran escala.
Significaba el uso de plantaciones
y de importar trabajo esclavo
del Caribe e islas de la costa africana.
El mundo del chocolate cambió
para siempre en 1828
con el prensado de cacao inventado
por Coenraad van Houten de Ámsterdam.
El invento de Van Houten separaba la grasa
natural de cacao o manteca de cacao.
El invento producía un polvo
que podía mezclarse con líquido
o podía combinarse con la manteca de cacao
para crear el chocolate sólido
conocido actualmente.
Poco tiempo después, un chocolatero
suizo llamado Daniel Peter
agregó leche en polvo a la mezcla,
inventando de esa manera
el chocolate con leche.
Ya para el siglo XX, el chocolate
dejó de ser un lujo solo para pocos
y se transformó en un placer
generalizado.
Dada la demanda masiva
se necesitó más cultivo de cacao,
que solo podía crecer cerca del ecuador.
Entonces, en vez de trasladar
a los esclavos africanos
a las plantaciones de cacao en Sudamérica,
la producción de cacao debería moverse
al oeste de África
proveyendo Costa de Marfil en 2015
dos quintas partes de cacao en el mundo.
Junto con el crecimiento
de la industria,
han ocurrido abusos terribles
a los Derechos Humanos.
Muchas de las plantaciones
del oeste de África,
que proveen a las compañías occidentales,
emplean trabajo infantil y esclavo
con un estimado de más de 2 millones
de niños afectados.
Este es un problema complejo
que persiste
a pesar de la ayuda ofrecida por
las grandes empresas chocolateras
a los países africanos para reducir
el trabajo infantil forzado.
Hoy en día, el chocolate se ha consolidado
en los rituales de la cultura moderna.
Debido a la relación entre la colonización
y las culturas nativas
y combinado con el poder de la publicidad,
el chocolate mantiene un aura
sobre lo sensual,
lo tentador,
y lo prohibido.
Sin embargo, saber más sobre su fascinante
y muchas veces cruel historia
como así también sobre su producción
actual,
ayuda a comprender el origen
de estas sensaciones
y de lo que ellas esconden.
Entonces, cuando abras
tu próxima barra de chocolate
tómate un momento para considerar
que no todo sobre el chocolate es dulce.